Italy's just so romantic oh you're gonna  die you're gonna have to drag you out of  here it looks like the relationships and  plot twists of the White Lotus are  continuing off screen co-stars Megan  Fahey and Leah Woodall who played Daphne  and jack on season two of the Emmy  award-winning show are reportedly  coupled up  [Music]  don't let her win  so earlier this week super sleuth fans  saw a very telling comment Megan left on  Leo's recent Instagram post reading I  love you I love these I love you I do a  lot of Dateline  husbands murdering their wives having  salon on vacation  [Music]  wow then in a post Megan shared of her  photo shoot with luk she included this  in the caption I love the UK and so of  course Leo a UK native himself responded  in the comments saying quote UK loves  you back it's our last day together  I want to show you around the island  please be satisfied and unlike many of  the White Lotus characters we hope this  real-life relationship survives